hello there reject nation I am Greg Alba
I am NOT I'm John Humphrey John and not
John are gonna watch Irish people all
you rich people try Jack Daniels whiskey
this is from the channel called the try
Channel I wonder what they do attempt
they attempt never seen this video
before I have seen this series before
and it is a lot of fun is it yeah I've
never seen any others haven't seen this
video but I've seen this year one of our
top of work here's on patreon whatever
video your question was doing put up on
YouTube today comes from Eric Horstman
the one and only surviving human being
with the real rejects tattoo has not yet
been killed for rockin that let's do
this it would be my first choice it used
to be my first choice
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
ten
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
how can you not look smokey
[Music]
[Music]
free
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's amazing incredible amazing it
tastes better than when you drink the
person just like
[Music]
seems like the guys can handle their
liquor much better in this video there's
a girl who looks like this Zooey
Deschanel meets Eva Green is really
funny next to like you know business
woman yeah classy elegant one yeah she
seems like she can really handle her
look too really well she seems like
she's into whiskey yeah she's really
into it like she was drinking on her own
time yeah men don't seem to be getting
drunk but the other people seem to be
getting really drunk here wait wait to
the best okay which one of them it isn't
whiskey I do not like whiskey
I'm a fruit drinker yeah yeah I'll have
a margarita more than anything you want
some that's friendly to the tasty I'm a
vodka cranberry kind of gentleman that's
fine I will drink whiskey if I'm in a
group and people are taking shots I like
but I generally am I'm a real [ __ ] when
I could
most hard I'll drink it I can handle it
but I never ever have like a desire we
lived together for like two years we
have whiskey and I never although what
was the drink that we got the Hennessy
that was pretty good
very strong yeah the cognac is something
else yeah I mean that's like $200 drink
or something like yeah it's a luxury
spirit yeah and I really like that but I
am with most of the people in this video
who do not like it but I love videos
where I watch people progressively get
drunk I you should see their personality
shifting you could see them becoming
looser and their body language and
having just more and more fun with the
process as time goes on yes I've always
wanted to do some kind of drunk show I
feel like that would be the best yeah I
once tried doing a reaction video never
went live where I was just kept drinking
as we get later there was one time I
remember we did a live stream where we
were drinking yes this is forever ago
yeah I got really wasted
I knocked out not during the business
but afterwards I did just still we were
in the car any thought wasn't like jump
out the car for hours this is pretty
complete but I did try well where I'm
like let me just keep drinking during
this reaction I got so drunk I never
posted it yeah it seems like a certain
amount of control to chaos like you
can't just get dry you have to kind of
time it out yeah yeah what was the
gimmick with the Irish people in Ireland
do they not have like Jack Daniels
whiskey is like a popular drink or
something like that no I think it's just
because it's a distinctly American
liquor and they do and Irish people are
known to be hardcore alcoholics all you
guys yeah oh you Irish people freaking
freaks summon blue alcoholic freaks to
them
just a freak they try a lot of different
stuff I mean sometimes it's like snack
foods and it's not always American stuff
but yeah this is always Irish people um
I think they have other kinds of people
but I know they have a whole bunch of
Irish ones interest and it seems like
this panel I there are a couple people I
didn't recognize but there are always a
few people who recur like the guy with
the glasses and the girl with like the
nose rings and stuff oh really and a lot
of them yeah so they might be an Irish
based channel could be could be yeah
freaking alcoholics drinking Guinness
into your bowl of Lucky Charms that's
right while you watch his whole world
own Scottish thing I don't want to get
him all mixed up now well I know Colin
Farrell probably pisses people off when
you do that he is yeah Harold's Irish
remember when we all first heard his
like legit accent these kinds of videos
just make me super happy because I just
love watching people get curious yeah
it's like do the drunkenness part is one
thing and then there's also just like
the people curiosity getting the best of
you my favorite one was the guy with the
red cardigan yeah right party with a red
sweater with the glasses he's my
favorite solo guy but my favorite duo
does have to be the two girls together
yeah great yeah they had a different
card they have a great back-and-forth
their energies are different their
chemistry is great there are two
different kinds of hot yeah best kind of
video you can get right there I could
watch a whole video with them and then
cut to guy in red sweater you know see
what he's up to
although the girl with him is pretty
cute too yeah I like the black guy yeah
so cooling combo proxy like he was all
about Jack did like a badass classy dude
yeah yeah like he's dressed like he's
gonna go to that confirmation ceremony
with the lady next thing yeah I know
actually all these people in this video
are pretty attractive
all right it's a sexy video now man I
would be sexy but not a tri average that
should do ugly people tried actively
reaction yeah that way it's relatable
you get all these good-looking people in
here it's not fair mmm I can't relate no
you can't compare because I use your
later ugly people drink a lot
ugly people will just only drinking a
hide away to forget that you're ugly
exactly thank you made they try to hide
it salted a group of people that
identify themselves as ugly and Irish
people the great thing is that everybody
feels ugly in their own way and
everybody probably who drinks has some
of that within their motivation for
drinking so in a way it's a universal
sentiment except if you're sober all
right well this is gonna be the new
channel that I watch on my own right now
yeah just go down the rabbit hole of
like oh I want to watch some try
everything this is one of those rabbit
hole channels that I'm definitely going
to be watching a little too much when I
should be is reading or something oh
yeah
all right well Eric thanks for
requesting this buddy Eric is constantly
sending me messages apologizing for
certain comments he makes our channel or
on patreon too bold Eric and he's always
like sorry I was super wasted the other
day I was super drunk this kind of gets
drunk like so often you should be on
this show you should be on which show
the the palette were acquired to really
I could see Eric being the guy who gets
drunk and then transitions into angry
drunk try salad darts like belittling a
PA yeah it's like oh this is funny and
then oh my god he is so abusive bring
another bottle
I really suit I could see him like yeah
you want it then he like cuts off his
skin Oh roof that on your subscribe
button
bell well Eric thanks for requesting
this guy subscribe to the tri channel
click the notification bell hit this
videos like button if you liked this
video look at you guys and yeah